alright now we're onto the monster right
part three let's read the whole thing it
is known that there's that big long line
there that big long line we're gonna
have to use that right
we'd have to prove it but we're going to
use it that's why they gave it to us so
the first thing I want you to do is
let's write that down write down that
result it's a bit long and awkward but
let's write the whole thing down anyway
[Music]
okay there it is they say don't prove it
but then they say all right now we want
you to work out now look read the
question carefully what is the actual
question asking us to work out what kind
of thing it's an area right it's an area
now nowhere in this question does it
actually tell you the method that you
need to use to find out that area but
look at the area where is this area I
haven't actually gone on my diagram yet
look down at the bottom of the question
or second last line actually where would
this area go on my diagram now remember
I said common theme between one two
three four questions very very few of us
if any of us actually used that picture
to help you do that area you just sort
of said oh I did part two part three
didn't say hints or otherwise I will
just go on my merry way as if it were
independent they're not independent
here's negative two roughly right
where's two somewhere over here
presumably
there's the area I've been asked to do
can you work out that with a formula is
there any formula for you know that
shape right that formula you memorize
for that shape oh no wait I didn't learn
any formula for that shape it's a
completely random thing I'm gonna need
integration here okay now see for just
put your pins down because we panicked
here and we just did not know what to do
we need to form an integral right the
question gave us a clue that doesn't
have an integral in it even though I
need an integral how can you be quick
how can you use this thing to help you
find an integral
[Applause]
hmm maybe you should go back go back to
question 12 party
you see you question 12 party Christian
12 party is the same question it's
exactly the same question just dressed
up a little differently in question 12
party we held your hand what did we tell
you to do we told you differentiate and
then you get you get something like this
you do working like this you
differentiate something and you get an
answer out the end and then in part 2 of
12 e we say Hantz integrate right and
that is precisely what we can do here
you've got a derivative you can use that
to form an interval okay
now the integral I what doesn't have any
peas in it there's no P so what am I
going to do what should P actually be
replaced by it should be replaced by 1/2
have a look at this guy over here look
at it carefully do you see if I put in P
equals 1/2 then I'll get my equation you
see that there it is there's that 1/2 X
up in the UM power okay so that's what
I'm going to do he's my working I'm
going to say let P equal 1/2
okay once you've done that you're gonna
get let's actually write this out you're
going to get this big awkward line but I
need this big awkward line
[Music]
you came with that do you see all I've
done is a substitution what are you
gonna use this for are you gonna use it
what am I gonna do to both sides have a
look what are you trying to find again
you're trying to find an area so I'm
going to integrate both sides but I'm
not just gonna do any integral right I
don't want an indefinite integral in
fact I want a particular integral which
one I want it between negative 2 & 2 and
you can see that's why I've drawn this
orange region right sir we go no I'm
still in blue okay when I integrate the
right-hand side from negative 2 to 2
that's just the statement of well this
will give me the area right from this
with respect to X okay blender this
left-hand side though my goodness this
is a bit of a mess but I'm just going to
when you integrate a derivative if you
just go back to the original theme right
so you're just going to get that that's
the thing you're evaluating
mmm I'm just gonna write the whole yeah
okay now the reason I put this light
here is because a lot of you got to this
point but you still didn't get the right
answer out so I want you to look
carefully and remember that all four of
these questions have something in common
which we struggled to do when we're
actually doing the paper this answer
here is not gonna work out really well
what's the problem when you have a look
at this area with this particular shape
that will not just give you the answer
just like that
what's its issue
[Applause]
there's negatives and positives if I
just do this if I just do this right
this negative part will be treated as I
should say this part beneath the axis
will be treated as negative right so
then it'll like cancel out with part of
this over here yeah does that make sense
but is that what the question actually
wants us to do it says let R be this
region and it doesn't say treat this as
negative treat this as positive we
actually have to treat that like a
positive area so in fact this isn't
going to quite do it for me right in
fact what I need to do from the graph
because I interpret from the graph that
there are some bit underneath but I have
to deal with I'm gonna say from they
have a look at the boundaries which part
do I want to actually reverse and turn
back to positive where are the
boundaries from where to where negative
two two or be careful it's to the
intercepts right so it's negative two is
negative one that's going to be this
integral I'm gonna want the negative of
that right I better finish off the
actual thing okay so being that I've put
a minus sign at the front it'll cancel
with the minus sign I get from here and
that'll give me that area right yes okay
so if you just did this this would be
okay in this case the reason why I'm
always a bit hesitant around absolute
values is that I just see lots of
students they just kind of throw
absolute value signs around because like
I don't know I want these to be I want
this doing to positive or that one or
that one I don't really know I'll just
put absolute value signs everywhere and
then students get confused so I would
prefer you to say I know that this when
I evaluate it will be negative how do I
know it will be negative because the
graph tells me it's beneath the axis and
I know how to restore that by putting a
minus sign at the front and then I know
there's this other area from look at
about the boundaries where is it going
from it picks up where the other one
left off and ends at two which is meant
to be the end of the boundary this Dada
Dada Dada Dada and now this you can do
with that top line there okay with
proper boundaries and that minus sign
that will give you the answer which I
can't remember but it's in the solutions
and you can look them up okay
so that question is hard but it's mostly
because you're intimidated by how weird
the working looks actually start there's
the answer it's provided to you that's
how much we want you to get this
solution